[Music]
welcome back to welcome back to Hannity
the great red state blue State debate we
continue with Governor Gavin Newsome
Governor Ronda santis uh according to
the Department of Housing and Urban
Development uh these are the numbers for
the homeless population in each of your
states it is a big problem around the
country in the state of California it is
172,000 in Florida it is 26,000
now the per capita numbers are pretty
much the same for California it is 44
per 10,000 people while Florida has 12
per 10,000 people so Governor DeSantis
uh I ask you why the disparity what are
the policies you are implementing that
is different from that of California
California is adopting leftist policies
Gavin Newsome was uh Governor or uh
mayor of San Francisco he put out a
10-year plan like 20 years ago he was
going to end homelessness then a few
years later he had another plan and now
he says he's going to do and it's only
gotten worse in the last 10 years in
California the homeless has gone up 45%
it's gone down in Florida 45% but it's
caused a huge problem with quality of
life in in California the people that
flee always bring up this they've really
empowered lawlessness and drug use and
you know Gavin new one point tried to
say that California was the freedom
State I just kind of laugh like you're
locking people down you're doing all
this but then I thought about it you
know California does have freedoms uh
that some people don't uh that other
states don't you have the freedom to
defecate in public in California you
have the freedom to pitch a tent on
Sunset Boulevard you have the freedom to
create a homeless encampment under a
freeway and even light it on fire you
have the the freedom to have an open a
drug market and use drugs you have a
freedom if you're an illegal alien to
get all these taxpayer benefits so so
those are freedoms they're not the
freedoms our founding fathers Envision
but they have contributed to the
destruction of the quality of life in
California and the results speak for
themselves people are leaving the state
because they have failed in addressing
the homeless population well I love I
love the rant on freedom I mean here's a
guy who's criminalizing teachers
criminalizing doctors criminalizing
Librarians and criminalizing women that
seek their reproductive care you're
making it harder to vote you're Banning
books I mean spare me this notion of
Freedom ask the folks at Disney about
freedom and free enterprise ask the
folks at the Special Olympics that you
threatened to fine with 27 million
because they were discriminating against
the athlet
Sy that is wrong that's being a liberal
bully that's being a bully syndrome and
you wanted to discriminate against 27
milliona because they were
discriminating against the athletes they
wanted to marginalize the athletes and
you wanted the athletes marginalized
that was wrong what you did these are
kids with Down Syndrome that just wanted
to comp up ad kids I've been working
with special Li all my life you wanted
them to be you wanted them to be
ostracized you talk to from Florida got
to partipate we stood up for this is you
treat yeah I by the way no hold on let
me say I can handle that I can handle it
I'm used to that but you know what your
attacks on the trans
Community Comm you attackable
commun and we made sure they relax I can
handle it I'm used to bully you're
nothing but a bully understand that
intimidating and humiliating people
that's your calling C why you want
the going for you why do you want them
not to be able to compete how well is
this want to be
going why you want to
discriminate the blueprint he wanted
them to exuded from the Olympic has put
Ron 41 points down Donald Trump as you
try to get tough out Trump TR let go
back to Hom isue of homelessness has
been an issue for decades decades in the
making in the state of California ever
since we started shuttering down our
mental health institutions back in the
day in Ronald Reagan's day the
difference is I'm the first governor in
California history to take this head on
we are investing unprecedented resources
more accountability we've gotten 68,000
people off the streets close to 6,000
encampments we've gotten off the streets
we've also invested in unprecedented
resources in reforming our Behavioral
Health System Ron has has literally the
worst mental health system in America
forgive me outside of of Mississippi and
Texas and so with all due respect to
being lectured on some of these topics
Ronda San is not the one I'm going to be
listening 30 second response you're uh
well I'm looking at total time Governor
Des
abouts it this is a map of San Francisco
there's a lot of plots on that you may
be asking what is that plotting well
this is an app where they plot the human
feces that are found on the streets of
San Francisco and you see how almost the
whole thing is covered because that is
what has happened in one of the previous
greatest cities this country's ever had
human feces is now a fact of life except
when a communist dictator comes to town
then they cleaned up the streets they
lined the streets with Chinese flags
they didn't put American flags there
they cleaned everything up so they're
willing to do it for a communist
dictator but they're not willing to do
it for their own I want to get in with
the limited time we have left I want to
get there are two very important issues
we have not hit hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else